[Musique]
l'ukraine sa fabrique tout tout tout
tout tout depuis que la guerre tout a
augmenté dans l'ailé les chaussures
augmentée n'est souvent pas augmenter
les dix heures tu veux augmenter tout
est fait en ukraine l'ukraine du public
tout pour le monde entier mais ça on le
savait
et puis tout
dépend des pâquerettes et les nouilles
dénisoviens d'ukraine est lamentable
tiens la boutade depuis mon talent il ya
plus de mokdad croyez pourquoi être la
moutte al sadd et dijon omar fait dijon
10 ont en réalité bastien ronny heer
garde sur la route la jeune je sois en
ukraine apparemment je savais pas ce
soit en ukraine on arrive à dijon et
badigeons entre kiev et moscou
[Musique]
c'est même pas de cadre de l'epu la
chatte elles sont coincées en ukraine où
sont passés quelque part d'actions qui
compte quelque part mais où est déroulé
que la route
ça fait mal ou alors on nous prend
vraiment pour des lapins